you are the best dressed uh guest we've
ever had i believe everything i'm sorry
sorry joe i'm sorry no no you should i
hope your job at the hardware store goes
well uh
enough but seriously
uh gardening one seat over here that's
it you're out baby yeah move down the
line you cannot compete when it comes to
style uh i got to interview you uh at
comic-con and you there two you were
dressed to the nines you've always
appreciated good clothing your whole
life you know i have it came from
observing my father giovanni and he had
a very small budget but he had a big
heart for clothes yeah and i used to go
into his closet and i'd just wander
around and touch the cuffs of his
jackets and feel the material he used he
was from napoli naples italy i'm half
italian half black and the italians have
all the style but my dad instilled it in
me and you know i got to tell you i did
a play once and it describes it all it
says top and bottom you get shoes and
the hat if you got that going on nothing
in between is going to be looked at so
can i tell you something yeah top and
bottom by the way
i can't do i want to tell you something
i've never
i've never found a hat that i look good
in i've never there's something about
the shape of my head
this big rotting melon this irish melon
but i swear i mean for years people have
given me hats i try them on and people
just laugh when they see me in a hat you
would look really good can i have that
please you're moving into the beret no
this is you look it's just it just
doesn't work
i like that look can i have a bank loan
there you go
suddenly mary poppins i know i know i
became mary poppins
uh what about uh okay we know you dress
well what about ever experiment with say
different hairstyle because when
someone's really interested in their
clothes they tend to experiment with
other aspects of their look no doubt
about it you know i'm known for you know
doing my hair in different directions
for film and spike lee when i did do the
right thing up until the final moment
the day before we shot what are you
gonna do with your hair what are you
gonna do with your hair and i said spike
i'm gonna do something with my hair so i
had a way out hairstyle with one edge
cut one way and one side cut the other
way uh but you know back in the 80s i
really wanted to be a rastafari
so i grew my hair and i had dreadlocks i
did a film with madonna called
desperately seeking suits oh my god
that's right that's right i was on the
street selling her wares
and then i would you know do some
fundraising and i remember there's a
shot my daughter it's her favorite shot
of me in a
shiny blue suit the only thing that's
wrong is the dreadlocks let's see i
think we have that photo let's take a
look there you are there i think you
look fantastic what's wrong i see
nothing wrong okay you like that
mustache it's not so bad either huh